so now I've got volume but I've got it
as a function of r and h ok so now I
need to get rid of an R or get rid of an
H so the question is which one should i
get rid of now i should say you really
can't choose either you actually care
and the mats will work out just fine ok
but what is easier than the other now
which would you get which would you
guess is easier to get rid of now the h
is easy to get rid of the question is
how do i know the h is easier to get rid
of that we are ok and the answer is it's
not square ok if i were to replace the
are with something in terms of HS i'm
going to introduce a square root in
there right so this will be in terms of
something like H and there will be a
square root of h bla bla bla bla times H
and there will be my formula for volume
fast gross don't want to do that so
therefore I'm going to get rid of ah now
the question helps you a lot here and
I'm going to help you like you how are
you going to get a relationship between
IH that won't allow you to eliminate
them out ok now the question gives you a
huge hand and it says by similar
triangles now where are the triangles
yeah you should have it's quite cold
really where are the triangles let me
help you see them again I gave it to you
the hottest form so wouldn't just like
be obvious to you here where the train
goes up here here and here ok now dad
all right oh I didn't really need that
ok so there weren't triangles that were
obviously but trying this is what I'm
going to use now how do I endure how did
I know to go apart for having done this
question before I mean a relationship
between r and h it's clearly going to be
a relationship of proportionality right
there proportional to each other as one
gets bigger the other gets smaller um
just to use your telling which its
inverse variation ok as the radius is
bigger a high gets smaller ok so if I'm
thinking proportionality what kind of
geometry gears me proportional
relationships relationships that are in
ratio
and the answer is similar triangles yeah
everything is so it's inscribed so it's
the biggest I can possibly get okay all
right now to help you see a little clue
because in a bit at the moment it's in
the middle this weird gross 3d diagram
let's draw this just as a cross section
okay so I just sliced across and you can
see I've got this triangle here I've
drawn it over here when I look at the
cylinder side on it's just a rectangle
yeah like that ok now I've got a whole
bunch of dimensions on right I know what
the diameter sorry the radius of my own
cylinder is I also know what the radius
of the UM the current is its lower case
okay which makes this little Donuts in
here this will game what's it equal to
minus bigger smaller mine's bigger I
think right now and reptiles times on I
didn't forsake yeah okay so good I've
set up all of this I do it all together
so that I don't be example toy on notice
to our medical pot right what am I got
here what's the height of my cylinder
its capital age right another age ok and
then I've got the height of the big
thing which is no edge ok now I could
call this H minus H I'm not going to
because I don't need it now the question
is how I know that I don't did it I've
got everything I need for my solar
triangles what aren't similar titles
where are they
there's this for what and there's a big
one right now I can't choose a whole
variety but it looks to me like the
easiest ones I've got this triangle in
here that's a small one okay and then
the big overall one that makes up the
cone does that make sense can you see my
this one's more interesting to me than
this one you see why okay there's a
variety of reasons these one two three
they are all similar to each other ok
the reason why this way is more
interesting to me then this one is
because this one has both of the
dimensions that I'm offer it's got that
H then I'm trying to get rid of Cena
capital H and it's got the odds now if I
want to hear like the H that I'm trying
to get rid of would be sort of tangled
up with the other edge you see that I
could do it I could but I'd rather not
ok i just want H just on its own and
this is the triangle which has H capital
a just on its own which will make
eliminating it a lot easier okay can you
see I'm trying to guide you through like
you have to choose you have to make
choices about which direction are you
going it's not just laid out for you are
there's a formula you one two three okay
yeah absolutely now I'm drawing it out
in Italy like I said the actual question
just gives you the steps it doesn't
force you to think about the steps okay
but I'm harder to you the question will
just say off you go tell me what the
movie biz okay at the end I'll try this
all up in a bit nice deeper you'll see a
lot more obviously ok so now I've got my
triangles ready I've got this little
triangle I've got an angle key on which
is in common and then I've got a right
angle here and a right angle here right
some epa yo all round is DVD yes like
that
okay think okay so i'm not going to
labor the point i'm just going to get
the statement out that i need depending
on the question they'll ask for more or
less detail but all i want is a
statement a proportionality right so
I've got a little triangle here right
the big h what does it correspond to
what side does it correspond to I'm
comparing one triangle to another right
so corresponds to the height of the big
triangle high in the little triangle
hiding the big triangle yes it's a bit
confusing that they've done big a little
backwards but video okay what am I going
to compare that to I'm going to compare
to this width and this with do you see
that little wit be with okay so I've got
our takeaway are all over little up are
you okay with that can I always there
all I wanted was to get rid of that H
right so if I get him on his own like so
it doesn't look very nice but don't
forget little age little R little R
again they're just numbers it just
numbers so I'm done that's it right
that's what I'm going to use and put it
into the volume ok so now I can say
therefore the volume is not in terms of
two variables but just in terms of one
PI R squared and then this guy right h/o
motors are all over ah it looks weird I
don't we but how many variables are
there there's just one there's just the
capital R okay so I'm there I'm ready to
differentiate with respect to the radius
okay which is really good i'm in a good
position that was some hard mental work
okay i'm like i said you often get
guided through it but i wanted you to
sort of work with it before you knew an
answer okay now would do one more thing
before i start differentiating this is
um what what category of functions is to
differentiate right this second what
does it look like
persuasion seen it interestingly right
you can answer this in a couple
different ways not why you can take oh
it's a question because I have a
division right be like we're haulin sec
it's not really a question because that
number now they're well it's just the
number okay so i might as well put my
five or ten okay that's fine so then
what I'm that dude is this guy up here
which is a product right it's this time
this okay I could do Pratt rule but why
do you go through when I can reduce it
to a polynomial right that's much better
so even though this is why this is the
air time this is the volume in terms of
the radius I'm going to do one little
thing to make it a little bit later I'm
going to pause this guy at the front
that's the that's the coefficient right
and I'm going to put that capital R
square inside right I'm going to expand
that a little bit so we're going to get
this which looks like it's worse than
this right because like wait this is
factorize why don't you like factorize
or more it's like but i don't want to i
want all of the variables together and
all the constants as much as possible
separated out so i can just grow beard
differentiate itself okay which i'm
about to do so DV or dr equals okay now
because that guy at the front is a
constant i just write him down no big
deal okay and then to do with this it's
just a polynomial those fancy rules
required okay so what does this become
too little R big R you can see I'm
writing the constants up front and this
guy becomes three capital R squared done
that's not hard right in fact it's all
really downhill from here